foreign
the economic cost alone of the loss of
Nature and biodiversity arising out of
the unabated release of carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere is estimated at
about 44 trillion dollars
we need to reimagine the way the world
produces consumes and prices energy
and we need to do it now
and so I'm here to tell you a love story
the lovers in this story might seem
mismatched
but their love has the power to change
the world by reimagining the global
Energy System
it's a story we all need to understand
a story with a complicated meet cute
But ultimately a simple resolution
it's the story of an electron
and a water molecule
now in order to truly empathize with my
electron's narrative Arc you need to
know a bit about her her history her
personality
electrons have powered the modern world
since the 19th century when scientists
discovered that using magnets and coils
of wire they could turn a flow of motion
into electrons carrying energy
that was just the beginning of our
increasingly electrified existence
behind almost everything we do there are
Supply chains refrigeration systems data
centers and much much more
and so it's perhaps not surprising
that the global production of
electricity alone constitutes about 28
of total emissions of carbon dioxide
because for much of that time
electricity has been produced by burning
fossil fuels which emit carbon dioxide
as a byproduct
but not our heroine
she's a green electron her energy comes
from the sun the wind the tide and
unlimited renewable resource which
produces electricity without emitting
any carbon dioxide
and there is good news here the share of
Green electrons in the global
electricity system is approximately 30
percent and it's rising rapidly
so
in that case addressing climate change
should be easy we just need to Electrify
everything
and make sure that we have enough green
electrons like her to power it
no
I identify very strongly with the green
electron perhaps because I've spent
virtually all my professional life
working to deliver her at the greatest
possible volume and the lowest possible
cost
but our green electron can't save the
world on her own
and that's why this is a love story
and not a coming-of-age narrative
electrons can't save the world alone
yeah the world also needs molecules
now I think of molecules if not as
exactly opposite to electrons certainly
is complementary
if I were to ascribe a personality to a
molecule it would be consistent
reliable
self-contained
unlike electrons molecules are excellent
at storing and releasing energy
efficiently
they're critical for industrial
processes which need the intense heat
which come from burning a fuel
they're essential for long distance
shipping and Aviation which need to
store transport and release energy
efficiently
but these sectors which are critical to
the global economy they can't be
electrified efficiently
and these hard to Electrify sectors
they currently equate to about 30
percent of total annual carbon dioxide
emissions because virtually all their
molecules come from fossil fuels
and until recently there wasn't a viable
alternative to obtaining those molecules
from fossil fuels and so no credible
route to Net Zero no possibility of
reimagining the global Energy System no
world that runs entirely on green energy
but
here enters our second lover a molecule
of H2O
water
not a traditional pairing with
electricity
but as Emily Dickinson reminds us the
Heart Wants What It Wants
and so our love story goes like this
the green electron and the water
molecule meet
they feel a spark they fall in love
and from that love is born a green
molecule a molecule which can store and
release energy without any fossil fuels
getting involved
oh
or further scientific version
using electrolysis the power of green
electrons can be used to split water
into its constituent Parts oxygen and
hydrogen leaving us with hydrogen H2
hydrogen is an extremely flexible fuel
it can be burnt to provide energy for
heat intensive processes like steel
production
it can be synthesized with biogenic
carbon non-fossil based carbon to
produce methanol and that methanol can
be used to decarbonize the chemical
industry or as a fuel for long-distance
shipping
that methanol can be further synthesized
into e-kerosene jet fuel which raises
the possibility of emissions-free
long-distance Aviation or finally
hydrogen can be synthesized with
nitrogen to produce ammonia
so now surely I'm going to tell you that
they all lived happily ever after like
all the great love stories in a world
that runs entirely on green energy
but no
because at the current rate of progress
of deploying scaling up these
Technologies we are absolutely not on
track to achieve a one and a half degree
pathway
but we are still writing this story
we know that industry can scale up these
breakthrough Technologies very rapidly
because it usted we've done this before
in 1991 we installed the world's first
offshore wind turbine so close to shore
you could swim around it
back then offshore wind was expensive
widely considered to be uneconomically
viable it was based on immature
technology there was a lot of doubt
about its long-term viability
but we committed to bring down costs we
optimized every component we work with
the supply chain so that they could
invest in their manufacturing capacity
and as the European policy makers saw
that we and the industry the progress
that we were making on cost and on
efficiency they reimagined the European
electricity system to put offshore wind
as a critical pillar of it
and the U.S and Asian markets like Japan
Korea Taiwan and of course China
have followed
and now we need to take the green
molecule on the same Journey
but much faster
in may we broke ground on Europe's
largest e-methanol plant
in Northern Sweden
in 2025 when it's operational it will
produce enough green methanol to power
one
ocean going container vessel
we're already planning the next five to
eight times the size in the US on the
girls coast and all over the world
developers like us are working with
companies who want to de-fossilize their
operations to build green hydrogen
projects
but the global Energy System cannot be
defossilized by individuals
even those in love
not by individual projects no matter
their scale not by individual companies
even whole countries acting alone cannot
transform the global Energy System away
from one which is dependent on fossil
fuels
until now
the price
of fossil fuels has not reflected the
true cost of the unabated release of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere it
does not reflect the costs of adaptation
and mitigation to a changing climate
and so those costs they fall on all of
us
inevitably
they fall on us inequitably
and that must change
too often the cost of de-fossilization
whether of companies
cities countries it's dismissed as too
expensive
and yet if the price of fossil fuels
reflected their true cost the economic
imperative would be to seek out the
defossilized version
the economic imperative would be to
scale up these Solutions we already have
at hand
a world which runs entirely on green
energy
it's not a luxury
it's a necessity
and so to come back finally to my love
story
in the UK where I'm from
there's a moment in the wedding ceremony
which recognizes the importance of
communal action
it's my favorite moment every time
because it reflects the fact that
marriage is an intensely private Act
families families of all kinds
it's a societal Endeavor it's a product
it's a component of society
just like my love story
and so in this the story of the electron
and the water molecule who meet fall in
love who produce the green electron who
has the power to reimagine the world's
Energy System
I believe that they
and therefore we
can live happily ever after
but only as in the marriage ceremony
only with the support of their family
and friends
in the UK the traditional response to
the question
will you support and uphold the
newlyweds now and in the years to come
is we will
and for our lovers
will we
their family and friends
government industry Society consumers
voters will we support and uphold them
we need to
we must
we will thank you
foreign